teenager has been arrested following a
shooting in suffolk
a 15 year old boy has sustained serious
injuries after the incident in
kesgrave sky's katie spencer joins us
from west london katie what do we know
so far
we know that uh this shooting took place
at around about 8 40 this morning
at about the time that students would
have been uh heading
into school uh a few more details have
been confirmed within the last hour
though from suffolk police who have told
us that
uh the boy that was shooted was a 40 a
15 year old boy
uh sorry who was a student at kesgrave
high school the school themselves had
confirmed a little earlier that it was
one of their year 11
pupils who was involved in this we know
that at the scene air ambulances were
called
to treat this 15 year old who's been
taken to
a nearby hospital and has sustained
serious injuries according to what the
police have released in their latest uh
update
um we know that as well as that police
have said they are
do have a teenager in custody at the
moment that they are talking to
and questioning in connection with this
incident as well police have now
both said that their priority is making
sure uh that the other students at
kesgrave high school can feel
uh safe on their way home and they've
released a a statement in the last few
minutes uh from
assistant chief constable rob jones who
said we have now made an arrest as part
of the investigation and are working
with our partners in suffolk
and our schools to ensure that everyone
feels safe when they are collecting
their children from school this
afternoon
there will be more police officers on
patrol and to provide reassurance in the
area
i would ask for anyone with information
about this
incident to come forward and we know
that the school
has been in close communication actually
with the police throughout the morning
since this happened
the decision was taken between both the
school and the police that the safest
thing to do was
for those students uh to remain in place
and for
the day to carry on as it would normally
but clearly i think a lot of parents
will be wanting to
collect their students as their children
as soon as possible
police wanting uh really the parents and
children to uh
come forward with any extra information
and really asking for people to
get in touch if they did witness this
incident